now Europe's border agency frontex says
nearly 66 000 Russians have flooded into
the EU over the last week as men leave
to avoid being called up to fight in
Ukraine Latvia has declared a state of
emergency as its Frontier comes under
pressure and Kazakhstan and Georgia are
reporting tens of thousands of arrivals
DW correspondent to Maria katzamadza
reports now from a checkpoint on the
border between Georgia and Russia
thanks to the Georgians for opening the
Border it made it much easier for us
alone with friends children or family on
foot or by bike with or without pets
many of these people crossing the border
from Russia into Georgia are doing so to
avoid being sent to war DW's Maria
katamaze went to meet some of them since
the start of the mobilization in Russia
this checkpoint in neighboring Georgia
has been working in an emergency mode
thousands of Russians have already
entered the country trying to escape the
war in Ukraine Russian man along with
their families spent days and nights in
queues stretching for kilometers most of
the time without food and water the
price that they are willing to pay just
to avoid going to the battlefield
Ilya spent three days on the road Moscow
to absei vladicavkaz first by train then
by bicycle this is how he crossed the
border into Georgia
I cannot support what is happening in
Russia now I am against Putin's policies
I am against this War I think it makes
absolutely no sense I was actually
supposed to go to Japan for a permanent
residency in six months but I decided
that if everything closes down there
won't be any Japan
Nikita's originally from Moscow he
worked for an energy company which
closed down because of the war he'd like
to return to Russia someday when Moscow
changes its political course
there is a huge influx of cars a huge
influx of people but I understand the
Customs officers have figured out how to
deal with this situation and have
started to organize traffic and what is
interesting is people are also
organizing themselves
George is on his way from krasnodar to
visit relatives in Georgia he tells DW
the Border guards don't let everyone
through he took my passport and checked
to see if I was being drafted that was
it those who are being mobilized they
just turned them around just like that
there have been cases like this
the Georgian interior Ministry has
already announced it does not intend to
close the border with Russia the Russian
Federal Security Service has already
deployed military personnel and an
armored personal carrier to the frontier
to stop Russians fleeing their
mobilization orders
it's join our ego kuroptov who's the
director of the free Russia foundation
in South Caucasus he joins us from the
Georgian Capital to Blissey a full
disclosure Mr corroptev also has a
commercial relationship with
deutschevela he was at the border
between Russia and Georgia last night
welcome to DW what did you see there
good evening yeah of course migrant
Foundation First of all we assist
Russian political Exile but now we're
closely monitoring what's going on on
the border because it affects uh
security of Georgia and
um situation in Russia as well when I
was on the border I saw lots of people
coming at Southern's and people use
bicycles they use any means to cross the
border yesterday uh Georgian government
bought a police allowed people to cross
the border by foot so many people just
leave their cars far away and go by foot
to cross the border and to leave Russia
as soon as possible not to go and die or
kill someone in Ukraine the observation
there is very tan yeah I I'm I was just
going to ask about the what what they
were telling you about why they were uh
leaving
I would say that mostly like uh there
are various groups but mostly people are
living because they actually never
supported this war and now uh there is a
time to to Loop the country as soon as
possible they will never they don't want
to ever uh become a part of this
criminal act in Ukraine I mean the war
some people of course they uh they were
silent but just they don't want to die
and some people who even supported the
war now after this Putin step to
announce mobilization not too good
because they also just don't want to go
and either without any preparation but
mostly again majority is the people who
oppose the world all the time from the
very beginning and and so we have
Georgia uh obviously sharing a border
with Russia with its much bigger
neighbor this must uh put the Georgian
authorities under quite a lot of
pressure not just from the physical
number of people coming into its country
but also a political pressure from
Russia
I would like to remind that 20 of
George's occupied by Russian Federation
since 2008 so occupation and illegal
Russian military when Georgia territory
the first threat yes of course this uh
number of people coming fleeing to
Georgia going to Georgia is the threats
and uh government and special services
are monitoring distribution at the
moment there are no indication of them
um there were issues but of course such
a big amounts of people in the country
of
3.5.6 million people it's a lot and of
course it increases Uh Russian influence
in Georgia so Georgian Society is now
demanding to close the border right
thank you for joining us uh eagle
corruptive from the free Russia
foundation in South Caucasus
earlier I talked to corneli cacaccia
he's director of the Georgian Institute
of politics in the country's capital
Tbilisi I asked him if he sees a
noticeable surge in Russian arrivals
yes I think this is already visible
because we don't have exactly the
figures because uh almost every day we
have more influence of Russian citizens
but before that for instance weeks ago
there was some sort of estimation that
we have already 150 000 Russian citizens
in Georgia and that's a huge number if
you consider that Georgia is a small
country it just says a population is 3.5
million and also uh you know like
because we have um Visa free regime with
Russia basically a state Authority is
not really able to control who is
actually entering to Georgia from the
Russian Georgia border
given Georgia's Own difficulties fending
off Russian military encroachment how do
people there feel about the influx of
Russians seeking Safe Harbor in Georgia
yeah if we talk about the people uh of
course there are some people who
actually see maybe positive way but
there are some people and more and more
now the people who have see this with a
lot of concern uh which is a little bit
different than the government position
with Georgian government basically
doesn't see any problem with this
influence they see it as the opportunity
because they according to them these
Russian citizens they bring some
Investments here there was already like
dozens of Russian companies registered
here but the problem is that what
Georgian government is missing here is
that they see just short-term gains but
they don't see the for instance risks
which may emanate in long term or in
medium term and I think the Georgian
citizen here are very how does it
concerned especially there's a different
angle of this issue there's a security
issue because we know that some of these
citizens especially the new ones which
just arriving now it will see most of
them they actually had a military
service already that's why they're
escaping right so but we don't know what
is their um how to say uh AIMS in this
country and what will be the reaction to
um to the future plans of uh Russia so I
think there's a little bit ambiguity and
people are more concerned because the
people really want to have some sort of
strategic vision from the government
before it becomes a problem because so
far we didn't have any major incident
between Georgia and the Russians but I
think uh you know people are a little
bit concerned about this issue